and so you know it's interesting lolita
i think
you have you ever as an investor not
been on your a game
and maybe had a founder have an
unpleasant experience with you
when you were on the other side of the
table and then how do you think about
really investor behavior when they're
evaluating or working with
founders yeah so i i mean i think it's
it's hard to say
hey as an investor i've never i've
always been perfect or vice versa
the founders have always been respectful
because the the facts are that
on both sides of the table sometimes
there's
uh behavior that you'd rather not see
right
and i can tell you for example i i was
talking to a woman
of color at one point and it was
reviewing her
her deck i i jumped on the phone call i
asked her some pretty difficult
questions
and in terms of her business and she
actually took it quite personally
and uh later on messaged me
and and said um that i had been
i had i had been just like a white
investor whitening investor
yeah and it was actually a very shocking
moment because
it i i couldn't even i couldn't even
digest
that uh and so you know i i
and to be fair i i don't know like maybe
i was being
rude in my questions right and and
i think here i open up jason and i say
look with vulnerability sometimes even
if you're a person of color you can also
have bias
sometimes you can also be rude without
intending to
maybe you're having you know a bad day
and you don't know
and i'm not saying i because i don't
want to excuse myself in this situation
that is what happened
uh not all founders have had great
experiences with me based on this one in
particular right
um but on the other side
i i have had actually recently
i a founder reached out to me a woman
founder
looking to fundraise and i said i'll
write you a check
just send me this these are my due
diligence docs that i
i i need to look through and you know
basic staff yeah
i'll write you i'll write you a check a
couple months later
i get an email saying uh it was a bit of
a passive aggressive email saying oh too
bad you missed out on
on the round we closed with x y and z
and i responded and i said
i told you to just send me the term
sheet actually and i had gone through
this stuff and
and so that was a bad experience for me
sure so there's definitely i think what
people need to remember and listen i
train
the next generation of angel investors
with angel dot university
and what i see happen all the time is
people use these meetings
i think on the let's just start with the
investor side
on the investor side neophyte investors
people who are new to the game
in a lot of cases they might come to the
table
with a lack of humility and they might
be trying to prove themselves
that they're smart right and so they
they ask very cutting biting questions
and what i've trained people to do is in
that first interaction i just say let
people talk and let them feel heard
right
and you want it's not uh you want people
to come out of the interaction
feeling better about you then this is
what i train my team i want every
interaction with the founder i want them
to feel better about their relationship
with us and our brand
than they did when they came in so that
doesn't mean you have to sugarcoat it
but i do think you have to be careful
that if you're
too cutting or biting or critical uh
especially in the first meeting or two
um you're doing it wrong
it's not an opportunity for you to list
all the reasons why this will fail
because
and 80 fell so that's like saying
like oh you're gonna do something really
hard you'll fail oh you're going to the
olympics
oh you're going to the olympics oh you
probably won't win the gold it's like
yeah most people who go to olympics
don't win the gold
like that's the nature of going to the
olympics going to the olympics itself is
success
so celebrate that success and ask your
questions and let people come out of it
and feel better and i have had people
on their blackberries back when i was an
entrepreneur to date it um
you know i had somebody on their
blackberry while i was pitching and i
stopped the meeting and i
got very upset but i i didn't show the
how upset it was i just stopped
talking and i just stared at the person
until their partners kicked him and said
oh
uh and they said i just don't want you
to miss this because i flew up here to
meet with you and i've got 30 minutes
and
i just don't want you to miss this and
then they apologize for that you have to
be
super vigilant and careful because also
on the other side of the table founders
are putting themselves out there you got
to remember they might have gotten 50
no's
right and they might be just absolutely
exhausted
from this process which you pointed to
tom exactly how
exhausting this is so anyway and
i'm not perfect in interactions either i
had a lot of yc founders who
got upset at me because i just couldn't
understand their valuations
and i would say like uh yeah the
valuation makes no sense to me you want
12 million dollars
i invested in uber and you know com
for nine million dollars combined like
you're not uber or at the stage uber or
com was when i invested
uh and i just stopped doing that because
it just created too many bad feelings so
i stopped saying
i'm not investing because of the
valuation i just said i don't feel like
it's a fit for us
um but you know would love to keep in
touch and then if a founder really
probes me
i'll open up a little bit more about my
thinking you know
but it's kind of hard and i think making
people feel bad on the way out
or during the process is just
something you have to be really
vigilant about because we're imperfect
humans right